quand on est suppléant
d'un député on sait que un jour on peut
arriver à exercer ce pourquoi on s'est
engagé c'est à dire suppléer en plus
quand on est suppléant de Madame berger
qui est quelqu'un de très actif de très
visible qui a une énergie folle on se
dit évidemment si ça doit arriver c'est
sans doute avec elle et puis surpris
quand même voilà puisque quand ça arrive
c'est assez brutal tout s'accélère très
vite
[Musique]
il y a une commission dans lequel si
j'ai madame berger qu'elle a commission
culture éducation jeunesse et sport je
vais rentrer dans cette commission donc
focaliser sur ces aspects de l'éducation
de jeunesse de sport
c'est une bonne façon si vous voulez de
travailler pour moi parce que un des
credos ici dans ma commune c'est
d'améliorer le vivre ensemble alors le
vivre ensemble c'est une association de
plein de choses de plein de domaines
[Musique]
moi je ferai du Philippe Emmanuel ce que
je sais faire bon ça a l'air de pas trop
mal marcher je pense que j'ai une bonne
image de ma commune et tout autour dans
le territoire dans la circonscription on
fait plein de nouveaux projets on est en
train de transformer cette commune qui
était un petit peu endormie je cherche
pas à être un député de médiatique donc
elle faisait plein de plateau télé de
choses comme ça waouh non c'est pas trop
mon truc moi je vais essayer de
travailler le fond les actions
d'apporter ma contribution dans les
réflexions des différents groupes
que je reste dans le conseil municipal
et je reste dans le conseil
communautaire un cœur divine également
qu'on est en train de travailler avec
l'équipe
on n'a pas voulu faire de primaire parce
que c'est quelque chose qui finit par
abîmer tout le monde donc on est en
train de travailler et faire que parmi
ces personnes finalement un seul
candidat se dégage on y est presque
voilà
[Musique]